le chef de la diplomatie britannique
dominic rabat a affirmé aujourd'hui
qu'il était difficile de croire que
moscou n'avait pas donné son accord à ce
détournement de vol pour en parler ont
rejoint notre correspondante à moscou
vera goffman on soit on verra quelle a
été la réaction des autorités russes par
rapport à cette affaire
bonsoir ces chenilles la russie appelle
à ce que la situation avec le vol de
ryanair soit analysé non pas à la hâte
mais sur la base de toutes les
informations disponibles a déclaré le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov pour lui le fait que les
autorités
au pire le russes sont prêtes à
collaborer avec des experts
internationaux révèle d'une approche
raisonnable je vous propose d'écouter
nous appelons à ce que cette situation
soit analysé non pas à la hâte dans la
précipitation mais sur la base de toutes
les informations disponibles
surtout que le porte parole du ministère
biélorusse des affaires étrangères a
fait une déclaration détaillée et a
souligné qu'en ce qui concerne cette
question
les autorités biélorusses étaient prêtes
à agir de manière transparente qu'elle
était disposée à se conformer à toutes
les règles internationales et à garantir
une transparence totale y compris si
nécessaire
en accueillant des experts
internationaux juniors
je pense que c'est une approche
absolument raisonnable je tiens à le
souligner une fois encore il est
important d'évaluer tout simplement
cette situation à tête reposée d'autant
plus que je souligne une fois de plus
les autorités biélorusses sont prêtes à
fournir toutes les informations
nécessaires quant au porte-parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov il a déclaré qu'il
existait certaines règles
internationales et que ce sont là les
instances internationales qui doit
redonner une évolution et verra les
autorités russes qui n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler d'autres affaires similaires
comme l'atterrissage forcé du président
bolivien 7 et en 2013 oui effectivement
le mr russe des affaires étrangères a
publié une déclaration
ce soir où il détaillait justement les
incidents semblables qui ont eu lieu
dans la pratique internationale comme
justement qu on vous l'avait dit
l'atterrissage forcé de l'avion du
président bolivien evo morales quand les
états unis ont fait de la pression sur
les ppe de et européens qui ont qui
recherchait à l'époque le lanceur d
alerte
edward snowdon quant à la porte parole
du ministère russe des affaires
étrangères malaise grave dans ce
communiqué justement publié dans la
soirée il a insisté que l'arrestation de
vollmann pertes à cilic était une
affaire intérieure de la biélorussie est
appelé l'occident à s'abstenir
d'appliquer deux poids deux mesures je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction
coordonnée à ces événements de la part
des représentants d'un certain nombre de
pays occidentaux vous et d'organisations
internationales dont l'union européenne
l'otan et le fce est surprenant qu'ils
exigent la libération de romane trop
tassés beach et l'introduction de
sanctions supplémentaires
les plus sévères contre la biélorussie
la compagnie aérienne bellavia je
voudrais vous rappeler qu'ils ont réagi
différemment à des événements similaires
qui s'était auparavant produits dans
d'autres pays et il existe de nombreux
exemples de ce genre
je vous rappelle que selon les autorités
biélorusses l'avion est dévié de sa
trajectoire à cause de l' alerte à la
bombe
les rapports de misc a affirmé que l'
alerte à la bombe à s'était révélé
erroné
après une fouille de boeing le président
alexandre loukachenko a quant à lui
donné l'ordre personnellement un avion
de chasse d'intercepter l'avion de ligne
après cette alerte a déclaré son service
de presse merci verhaeghe hoffman
correspondante à moscou